today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza
gray block pizza 1811 pico boulevard in
los angeles
if you want pizza then you want gray
block
get that hitter baby today's episode is
also brought to you by magic
mind flow state now comes in a bottle
and flow state that's not a woman that
you met somewhere maybe outside of
detroit
flow state now comes in a bottle matcha
not tropics nautropics adaptogens
and a hint of honey it's the ultimate
nemesis to procrastination
magic mind get magic mind
use promo code theo to get 10 off magic
mind
dot co today's guest was the
second overall draft pick in the 1989
nfl draft and maybe the largest
offensive lineman that people had ever
seen he was on the cover of
sports illustrated he's lived many lives
to say the least we're going to hear a
lot about that and he's transformed his
own life
uh through the power of recovery he is
a retired athlete um
motivational speaker and photographer mr
tony
[Music]
manderick
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for coming man my friend morgan
murphy do you know who she is she's a
right she is a writer
she messaged you i think she never met
her one time right that's what she said
but she messed me yesterday she's like
oh i'm so
excited for this i'm such a big tony fan
she's a huge fan of his uh yes she's a
comedian yeah and a writer and she's
like i'm such a huge fan of his
photography right
yeah she um i want to say about six
months ago messaged me
or had commented on dm on instagram
uh and then i kind of looked her up
because i saw she had that
seal like that she was who she was right
so i was like well i just wanna
because i didn't know who she was so i
checked it out i was i was like
oh you know she's a comedian and she's
been to i think tempi improv and all
that stuff
yeah yeah she's a yeah she goes over to
the comedy store a lot of our fri
i know are from and then she's written
on a bunch of shows but it was just
you know it's just interesting the
people that will reach out when you have
a certain guest coming right right
and it always uh it always surprises me
yeah i told her if she's ever through
phoenix yeah that's what she said she's
like she just hasn't been i guess that's
what she said she's like tell him i i
plan on
on seeing him at some point cool um yeah
she's definitely worth i mean
a lot of people are worthwhile yeah she
seems very straight up very
authentic she's cool chick yeah and or
cool whatever she is man i mean
she's a woman but yeah cool person um
t-q-y-n yeah i don't know what letters
to say these things my friend juggles
now and he said he feels left out so
i want to call him the alphabet yeah i
know that's not referring to her i'm
just talking about
oh in general it's hard can you imagine
going to get your license now
male female hispanic ghost great yeah
like i'm the alphabet somebody yeah
but the thing is it's just going to add
up until it's just everything and then
it's going to come full circle it's so
stupid
it's some things are getting absolutely
ridiculous man um
you live where do you live these days
i'm in scottsdale oh nice how do you
like it over there i love it i've been
there since 04.
oh 405. and what spurned the move over
to there
you know it was kind of
i had a golf course in canada where i
grew up and
it was family owned down half of it and
i was just tired of
you know how family businesses can go
awesome or they can go
hmm not so good so
it didn't go like really bad but it
wasn't like i wasn't
i guess receiving what i was promised i
was gonna receive
okay so i was kind of like instead of
making a big deal about it i'm just
going to
get out of the business and instead of
giving them a two-week notice i give
them a nine month notice
okay just so you know they could figure
things out and stuff oh yeah
like a baby yeah right i mean it's
plenty of time to figure stuff out
yeah i'm not just gonna leave them
hanging so
i like literally sat at the kitchen
table and i was like if i could do
anything anywhere where would it be
and it was photography and it would be
in the southwest although i didn't know
if i was going to go nevada cali
uh utah or arizona
you know i think arizona was the pole
for some reason probably because of
sedona
yes you don't know i mean i'm only an
hour and a half from so lot of seances
up there a lot of women a lot of a lot
of um crystals yeah
yeah a lot of crystals oh it's it's not
crazy it's an honor to drive by a
woman's house and see her charging her
crystals
out in the in the yard right right on
the full moon right she's putting all
she's wheel bearing them out there to
charge up yeah yeah
yeah it's um it's natural it's probably
my favorite place on the planet
but the crystal stuff it doesn't even
freak me out it just makes me kind of
go whatever yeah then i'll drop out of
this right
i'm like cool right whatever gets you
through it
exactly what it really is because what
works for me may not work for them yeah
right
it's kind of amazing how there's so many
different like um
whether it be relics or uh
deities and there's so many different
avenues for people to find
uh comfort yeah yeah i mean
yeah there is there's and then sometimes
they're like
i do i used to do a lot more than i do
now but i used to do a lot of
ritualistic things
maybe i shouldn't say ritualistic but
just stuff like
i would always tie my left shoe before i
would tie my right i would always put my
left shoe on before my right shoe like
before a game
or just in day-to-day living
and then i forced myself to break that i
just said
i was like i'm going to live wild on the
edge i'm going to put my right shoe on
first oh yeah
and i was like oh nothing happened today
that was bad so i'm good
you know i'm going to tell you i'm going
to put this right in my neck
so you uh you started
you so was it hard to leave canada when
you left canada was that tough
when i left the golf course when i went
left for school
when you left uh the golf course when
you yeah it was it was
canada is awesome it's freaking awesome
i love it i mean
you know i i you know i grew up in
canada until i was 15
and then my senior high school went to
ohio for the sole purpose of
besides the obvious of graduating from
high school but to get exposure to get a
scholarship
to major american college because it was
easier by if you were in the states
yeah and then it just so happened at the
high school i ended up going to
was in the same town as where my brother
was going to college at kent state
so he would become my legal guardian so
like
really go to court and everything my
parents had to sign off wow
and they got you a home down there no i
actually ended up living with my brother
wow on an off-campus apartment and were
you guys was that like kind of party
central are you are were you so focused
on that time at
on football i was very focused but there
was yeah there was some partying like i
mean it was
it was the first time i ever got drunk
was believe it or not a senior high
school
yeah i mean a lot of people will
surprise a lot of people right
first time i ever dabbled in
weed was for my senior high school yeah
so yeah so for some that would almost
seem a little bit late in the yeah yeah
yeah um what what is your height and
weight now what are you at now
i'm 6'5 probably about 265 270.
and what were you at when you were at
your maximum beefed out you know
butcher box the heaviest i ever got
or the biggest i ever got was like well
i was six six i was an inch taller
but the compression gravity catches oh
yeah um
gotta pull you back down right right
right maybe four foot
it's like one of those i'm glad i didn't
get what i really deserved right
oh totally man but um i was like 333
was the big like off-season biggest i
got and it was like just
slinging weight around heavy but playing
weight that was not a good playing
weight
it wasn't a good playing weight that's
you right there damn bro
my god if i was a shark and i saw you
off surfing i'd bite you bro
no homo bro you know or yes homo i don't
know what they're doing now
what is it like carrying um what was it
like carrying that much body weight
around
did was there anything that started to
be different i've used steroids in
myself growing up you know
so i have some experience of what it's
like to have a body that's different
than like
what did you take i took uh testosterone
and then some other things i don't even
know what they were so but you got like
did you gain like what 20 pounds 30
pounds yeah probably gain 30 pounds yeah
so that's a significant amount of weight
right of muscle
mostly muscle so you know that feeling
right
well here's the thing in the off season
i'd be like 333
and just to put muscle on put size on it
was almost like i don't want to say it
was like bodybuilding where they have an
off season and they're putting on weight
so they can cut down for a show but i
would try to do all my building and my
bulking in the off season
might give them all my strength and then
as the season got closer
and i mean like 16 weeks out we'd start
running
so you know as you're running it make
sure it leans your muscles out
and it's harder to keep like that big
bulk
yeah but a good like playing weight for
me was like 3
10. like at 3 10
like i can honestly tell you at 3 10 i
felt like i was 150.
wow i could like run like it was i was
like
i could stop on a dime and like that's
what i felt like yeah
and you know when you set up a scale on
your 310
but i think it's like everything was so
strong
like you know your core strong just from
even all that weight
i mean you have to work your core yeah
at that point if you're doing all the
power cleans you've been down to pick up
100-pound dumbbells i mean you're
on a late date right 100-pound dumbbell
150s 160s
totally right
[ __ ] meat here
oh yeah okay come someone jacked up i'm
like i never walked like that
you're at home you're curling your
grandparents yeah you're just like
right it's getting crazy right i'm like
you guys need to eat them do you
remember the first time that you when
did you first start is it okay to talk
about this kind of stuff okay cool
thank you if you're comfortable with it
i am man i am yeah
our audience a lot of our audiences i
mean i don't know what i mean a lot of
them i think need help and
uh but but we all do and that's kind of
where
our audience all kind of meets each
other is in that space where it's like
we're all imperfect creatures um do you
remember
uh so the first time you ever used
steroids
take me through a little bit i was a
senior my senior year high school in
kent
but it was i should say but that sounds
like i'm making
an ex excuse for it it was in
april may so it was like the last two
years
or last two months of my senior year so
i had already signed a scholarship with
michigan state so football was over you
had already been doing
really well at football yeah and you
know well enough
see i was lucky because our team our
high school team had like five
like like tier one um like marie cruz
right i mean they like you know ohio
like all these big schools were coming
to watch those guys
and the whole plan was let's keep our
fingers crossed and they noticed me
and they did and they did so so the move
down to america the move to
ohio the living with your brother all
that was really i mean you guys must
have been living
a little bit like wow this is all
panning out well yeah
yeah cause yeah yeah well then you put a
plan together right right so i mean we
literally put the plant on paper this is
the plan
and let's not continue the plan until
this gets executed because if it doesn't
work
then there's no reason for the other
plan right because i don't want to make
a plan b
right yeah as soon as you make plan b
you've screwed yourself on plan a it's
like oh i always got this to fall back
on
oh plan b has a lot of pizza in it right
i always know and the weed apparently
you know yeah and we
too nick gets all excited when we say it
but
that's only because but yeah but yeah
the sole purpose of the ohio move
was literally to get a scholarship
so you got that so as so right at the
end of high school so you start that's
when you get
that's when i started the steroids and
the catalyst was and i
told you about it my brother he did yeah
he was into it
yeah cool and he's you know my hero and
and my mentor my
little you know he passed away when he
was 31 from cancer oh
i was like 93 1993 february 8th to 93.
and uh but you know i'm sorry to hear
that man that's heartbreaking yeah it
was
you know and you know what's like the
toughest part about that is i was like
so in the bag messed up with alcohol and
painkillers at that time
you know it's like i wasn't there sober
right right yeah you weren't that that
wasn't pretty stuff that you didn't like
yeah
but you know it's like there's tools to
deal with that stuff you know and stuff
and i've dealt with it and i'm i'm good
with it
you know and but the what was he like
what was he like your brother started
interrupting he was
he was the best yeah yeah he was the bad
he he taught me so many things like
he taught me so many things that and and
did so many things that today would be
considered
abuse you know um
he made me i remember one time it was
like a friday i already got scholarship
and everything and
it was a friday we were working out and
so i'm a high school senior he's a
college senior and he's working out with
his
lifting partner who's a bodybuilder and
this is in kent and
ken at that time was a really small town
and um
i was just gassed i was tired and i was
like you know what i
i'm just gonna chill today i'm not gonna
work out i'm but i gotta go to the gym
because he's my ride home oh yeah and
the gym from the high school was like
walking distance and
the walk back to the apartments was like
two three miles hey
i mean it's not like it's not walking
does it but a huge snowstorm
oh yeah and and i was like i'm just not
gonna lift and
and i could see them both like shocked
and because i loved lifting but i was
tired and
they freaking ripped into me like it was
i mean it was life-changing it was
life-changing because
they were like tony robbins yeah no they
no
that would have been nice tony montana
yeah okay
yeah exactly okay yeah yeah yeah say
yeah say hello
um they uh
you know john smith who's
at michigan state right now in his third
year is gonna
you know not take it easy on you when
you get there you're gonna knock your
you know what off when you get there
he's like they're like
because i think that they thought and
and maybe i did or maybe it
seemed that way that i thought that okay
well i got the scholarship already i'm
good you know i can chill now
and i never really was like that
but they really were like you know
staying on top of you
yeah which is good right i think where
today it'd be like oh you're pushing
somebody too much it's like no look it's
support
i looked at it like they were supporting
me i had to walk home
in that blizzard oh man i'm so glad it
happened
oh i run a 4-1 and a blizzard
with the wind behind me i run about a 4
or 450 or 4. i run about a four one
twenty
four two five two eight two four well
you got some momentum going so you're
probably in the seven second mark
dude i run a job okay i'll be honest
with you
i run as fast as i have to did you think
do you think like looking back on it
that you did like
um because i get curious as to like i
remember i was working at a restaurant
they had a bus boy there
that was an older guy and he was doing
steroids in it
uh and so we would go to the gym
together and next thing you know it was
just like something we did
right you know and um and he was older
than me this guy so sometimes i went
looking back i wonder would i have done
it if it wasn't like an
older person if it had just been a buddy
i don't think too much on it but
sometimes i just like to look back at
like
you know where was like the influence
coming from or was the influence coming
from inside of me like wanting
something um different or wanting a
different experience you know wanting
to like put anything into myself right
to replace something inside of me that
was missing
right yeah which is the story of our
lives totally
right later in life releasing something
that's already inside of me yeah but i'm
looking for external answers
or external things to fill that void but
really the answer is inside of me
right yeah but it doesn't feel like it
is because it feels like there's nothing
inside
once you get sober clear-headed and kind
of can start reflecting on life as you
get older
yeah you that's when at least for me my
experiences i start to see
i was like the dog chasing my tail yeah
looking for this looking for that and
it's like the whole answer is like with
me the whole time
yeah it's just like stop take a look
slow down you know breathe
yeah but the catalyst for the actual
steroid taking was i couldn't
bench 315 because that's three big
plates on each side
oh yeah but i could do 295 for like five
reps but i couldn't do 315 for one so it
was like a psychological block and i got
on like some really light steroids and
like within two weeks i was like at
three
benching like 325. damn so i was like oh
they definitely work
well we got on some vietnamese [ __ ] one
time i don't even think it helped me
lift they helped me cook
it definitely helped me like i could run
dude i'm not even joking
i could cook over a fire suddenly in my
yard but i could not
[ __ ] do it yeah because we got some
gutter steroids that came through man
like we got like
bottom of the barrel was it like top of
it taped clothes
yeah that's like a wrist it wasn't even
sealed and stuff yeah
i remember one time we all went to
mexico on a class trip so we came back
literally people would buy starts and
then put them in shampoo bottles just
kind of rinse them out a little
no and just pour it in there so then for
like
people are just pulling up at this
dude's house and just syringing out of
this
you know head and shoulders unreal you
know and that's it i mean it got you
it got you both of those pharmaceuticals
[Laughter]
holy smokes but yeah we had some of the
cleanest muscles in town right we'll say
that
well you're willing to go to any lengths
right oh totally that's the question
that
it's like i really was yeah and so was i
and i am today too
in in certain areas of my life but it
was like
i'm gonna do whatever i got to do to be
the best player i can be within re like
within the rules
right but steroids were regular rules
so those were within the rules at the
time no no they were breaking the rules
they were yeah they were so and so there
was a day where i had to make a
conscious decision
it's like i'm not going to kill i'm not
going to sit here and lie to myself
because i wasn't like hooked on
painkillers i wasn't drinking
alcoholically or nothing like that at
that time
i was like is it worth it
and it was and it i it was yeah i mean
looking back
at everything and and you know what it
was worth it and the least amount of
that worth it is monetary
even though it made me it helped me make
millions of dollars right
the least the greatest worth and value
in that are the lessons learned
in life from taking them but
at the time you didn't know that though
right but i had to make a conscious
decision on
will i ever look back and regret and
saying like
what could i have been ah you know what
i'm saying so i was like i'm gonna go to
any lengths plus
and this is not to like i'm not like
blaming anybody but the
atmosphere was like you know the end of
the 70s that happened so this was
1983-84
so who won four championships in the nfl
in the 70s steelers
right i thought it was maze backers
steve no they were the ones that's right
i remember they won two in a row
or something bradshaw yeah and all those
guys and they're
like you know gary olshansky was out
there i don't know him but
but webster and uh steve course and all
these old linemen
they were i mean all jacked up right and
it was obvious
yeah and i was like in my head and and
my brother
kind of felt the same way was like the
only road to the nfl
is through steroids or at least it's a
spoke in the wheel
yeah and especially i think as a white
guy you got to get
you got to get on something you know for
what
i mean just no just oh i think no you
just got to get
if i'm a white guy i'm getting on
steroids you to play anything listen can
you imagine if you
if someone had a drug for that yeah oh
man um how rich they'd be
oh yeah well hell we sell them half of
our ads
it was like when i say this
i say it literally like um i
try not to be in too much gray area
because that's kind of how i lived my
life
and as the older i got i started to
realize
i thought i had to be in gray area
somewhat but it's not it's just being
more tolerant and flexible of the way
other people are
but i i can make it crystal clear on
what
i'm about and what i believe in and what
i don't believe in
um and then all the variables in between
so i knew i was taking them i knew it
was wrong i knew i was breaking the
rules whether i was taking pills and
injections or both
right um but i was like i'm gonna
you know their testing was so mediocre
yeah
and you know i think that
i became kind of like a red flag
to the ncaa because um
like we did them well right i should say
i did them
i did them the correct way to get the
most out of them and
i didn't like i held nothing back you
know in the training
and that was whether it was running
whether it was lifting doesn't
it oh i see you didn't try to mask that
you almost didn't even mask it you were
doing them you just hit it from the test
right and and i did like i didn't go
around telling people and i always
whenever the question was asked um do
you do steroids by the media
my answer would always be like i've
never tested positive for steroids
right so it's like you got to be pretty
dumb not to read between the lines
exactly yeah there's only two lines
right
[Laughter]
um if you had a comma there's only one
that's really true man there's uh
i remember one thing that got me i
remember about
and i've just we haven't had anybody in
here i don't think that's ev that has
ever done steroids that i knew of so
it's like
it's just for me it's interesting to
talk about because we talk about it on
the podcast sometimes over the years and
um so i remember being in class one day
and some kid was a new kid in class and
he thought i was going through the
the aisles picking up people's papers or
something for the teacher
and he thought i was the teacher's
husband
and i think because i've been doing
stuff i was suddenly looking for your
job
yeah just look stronger right and you
know
and i just the you know at that time the
thought that somebody
would you know i would be married to
somebody that knew first of all they
even knew mathematics as well as this
lady did
you know like it almost just was
flattering you know like holy
[ __ ] you think that's my wife that's
pretty much the older woman right she
drove here
you know what i'm saying like this is a
real lady over there um
but i just remember that one moment
that's like
i don't know i just felt like people saw
me i just felt
more confident i felt stronger my i just
and right right then man those feelings
were feelings that i never had
are they good or what oh right bro they
were so good right
they were so good and then uh but you
also did the work
you also worked out right oh i was we
worked out all right and i
you know dieted properly and i you know
you would get on milk thistle and all
these yeah
like things you would hear about to kind
of take care of yourself um
but it was definitely like it was
interesting how i went from if you
asked me two weeks before would you ever
do steroids i just said no way right
but then suddenly i was over a line
right
and for me in a lot of my areas of life
that that
became something sometimes i really
don't want to look at the truth that
there's a lot of lines that i've crossed
in my life
that i probably wish i hadn't you know i
remember thinking
oh i'll never hook up with a married
woman you know and then cross that line
just like right
things that like like where you're
saying like certain kind of boundaries
or where where who you
are and things that you do will and
won't do right i had those things
but i always went past them and then
would live and still probably live with
a ton of the shame from a lot of it
right and that's you know and
a lot of the stuff you described i mean
you're it's like were you following me
around
right right it's like yeah you know like
everybody's
done stuff that where they've kind of
set their boundaries or
these are my code of ethics like my
personal code of ethics
and then you know you cross them and and
you know i think when you're younger
at least the majority of the people i've
encountered as far as friends and stuff
the younger you are the more kind of
like yeah
screw it it's okay the older you get the
the road narrows
and stuff that you could do a couple
years ago or five years ago that were
maybe not the most ethically
you know right be a man stand up and be
a man like kind of thing because
standing up and being a man today is not
about
how big your muscles are yeah it's about
doing the right thing
it's changed a lot it's changed a lot
and and i think
i i think it's changed for the better
even though we're in a
present circumstance of debacle it's
been such a great year
to watch people and how messed up people
are and and
and to be like man i just want some
toilet paper
and it's not even a [ __ ] disease right
right and it's like why is everybody
hoarding toilet paper
and i was like like six rolls will last
me six weeks seven years
oh good yeah right it's like but there's
not on the other there was one march
april it was like nothing to get
yeah it just it just it was interesting
to watch people
panic because
you know you're sober i'm sober so we
know
like in a way like i feel lucky that i
had a lot of hardship because
and the reason i feel lucky is because
i've put perspective on it
and i've also the tragedy would be if i
didn't change it
if i kept living that way well that'd be
the tragedy right
and but it gave me perspective to change
it so my
four years in green bay were a train
wreck and i was
there wasn't you know a single day in
green bay where i was like
stone cold sober it was either some kind
of a pill in me
there was anything that would alter me
from the chin up right
in my brain where i was drinking or i
was doing something now that doesn't
mean i was sloppy down falling down
drunk drinking but i would need a drink
to stop the shakes
and then go to practice wow right what's
kind of hard to pass block
in the nfl period let alone when you're
half in the bag
yeah so you know looking back at a lot
of those things
and being going through all that pain
like i got
into so much emotional pain i was sick
and tired of my own [ __ ]
oh man that's to that's that's right
it's exactly where i'm at right now
and that's out of myself that's when we
change sick of yourself right like
literally people like what are you on
and you're like i'm on myself right
and it's [ __ ] killing me like it
people don't understand sometimes and
that's a lot of what i think addiction
is for me i don't even know sometimes if
i've ever had a lot of chemical
dependency
as much as i
the way i'm feeling affects me so
heavily
right like it's a drug like to the point
where it's like and then i become
addicted to it
and at the same time suffering from it
yeah and i think people sometimes can't
understand some of that like
what it's like to feel that way right
and it's and they're like you're a wimp
or you're this
man it's like you think i don't want you
think i want to
feel this way every day when i wake up
you think i want to be angry or be
miserable or you know like no this is
something that's happening
to me right it's hard to handle right
yeah and and
you know i mean listen you're it's like
again are you following me around
because you're telling me my story right
it's exactly how i feel and
i don't feel it i still get definitely
times like that
but less and less yeah and and it'll
change
i've been you know over 25 years now
almost 26 years sober
and wow but you know what like the first
three years were
like just like you could have cut me off
you could have done
robbed me i would have been like here
you go cool have a good day i was so
happy not to be miserable
yeah right oh the beginning of sobriety
when you're like
when you see when something happens
there's a perspective switch in the way
you see in the world in the way that it
really is
god bro yeah it went it literally like
you talked about the four or five days
or two weeks before you took steroids
you never thought you would take
steroids
four days before i got sober i never
thought i'd be in a treatment center
four days later wow
and that was a decision i made right and
because of the emotional pain and i was
just looking in the mirror and disgusted
at what i saw and all that i was like
what a
bunch of [ __ ] and lies and deceit
and just and it just gets so hard you
stack up so much stuff it's just too
heavy
and it's so interesting you had so much
weight on your body
like so much and it was like but then
you get this relief
of all of this [ __ ] weight crazy
isn't it which is just almost so ironic
and you're like it's crazy in your space
and today but in today like like you
talk about like today's circumstance
when i do feel the way like you know if
i feel like a shitty day or it's like
like i'm sabotaging myself or whatever i
know why it's because i'm not connected
i'm not either talking to people or i'm
not or i haven't like for me
i even hit my knees in the morning and
ask for help well when you're
i think that this is a powerful thing
when you're six five like now six five
265 whatever
when you hit your knees and you are
praying to the god of your belief
and asking for help through the day and
asking about what you can add to the
stream of life instead of sucking out of
the stream of life
for a change that's a pretty humbling
experience
when you're that big a stature so you
know i was doing that when i was
six six you know playing for the colts
at 6 6 3
three twenty strong as an ox
and it's it's a very humbling experience
knowing you're
knowing how powerful you are right and i
could make stuff happen
like i can make things happen by the old
phrase just grab the ball by the horns
just make it happen
if you got to step on people's toes do
it just make it happen
it's like i don't care how you got to
block this guy just don't get a penalty
and block him i don't care if you got to
take his knees out whatever right it's
like go to any lengths to protect your
quarterback
so it's it's kind of like that but it's
like you know it's
when you have that stature that size
that power and you're in the weight room
slinging weight around and all this but
in the morning
you know when you get on your knees and
ask for help that's a humbling
it's a humbling act yeah and yeah
and you know it's like it's basically
saying you know i can't do this by
myself
i tried and almost killed myself yeah
almost killed myself
trying yeah because i'll never forget
when i'm in the treatment center in
detroit
and there was no fancy treatment center
and this was the first time you ever
went into treatment
first time so you went in and got it
yeah i'm not gonna do it again right
yeah um and uh okay take us there no
girl the girl the lady counselor it was
our first like small like
10 people session with a counselor and
it was all our first time with this
meeting and she goes
um so before we start she's like this
isn't pointing anybody out she's like
this applies to everybody she's like
just before we start i just want you all
to know that all of your best plans
of building your empires and building
everything got you here in this
treatment center in detroit michigan
and i can see like i know you know
or whatever it is going by the
interstate i'm going she's right
and i was like talking about a
louisville slugger coming across your
forehead going holy [ __ ]
that reality yeah yeah i mean
funny now wasn't funny then
yeah but i'm trying i'm trying to think
of some of those first moments that
you know whenever i went into the rooms
because mostly i learned about recovery
through my family my
i have siblings that are you know in and
out or been in the program and um
and probably my father i mean i think so
many people struggle with addiction to
different things
but i remember getting i remember i
drove through the parking lot one night
of a
of a room that's not far from where i
live and
i was talking to my brother something
the next day and he said well you know
who's not thinking about getting
treatment
and i said he i said who he goes
people that people that aren't driving
through that parking you know i'm saying
like not everybody's driving through the
parking lot of an aaa
center last night you know what i'm
saying like there's something inside of
you that's
curious that's thinking like and i think
sometimes it is there's a magnet
that's created by that program um
you know last night i went to a meeting
and i went over to a buddy's house and
uh and i got there and i hadn't been in
probably like three months to his
meeting and
um it's just like six or seven guys
sitting outside by
fire right and i get there and suddenly
like i walked around the group and just
hugged like every guy there i know them
all right
and it was funny because i just had the
worst day and i get there and uh
and i was like man i didn't know that i
was gonna hug all these guys when i got
here i forgot that
and they were all so excited to see me
like each individually we have our own
little relationship and like
i just i forgot that all these guys
cared about me and i forgot that i cared
about them like it's just like
camaraderie yeah and unless i like the
half-life or the
residual effect of like care it doesn't
the shelf life isn't long inside of me
for some long it's
you know it's really it's almost like
the shelves are like at an angle and
when somebody puts care on them
they just slide it just and i don't know
why i think it was just the way the
shelves were built or something you know
but
it was just crazy because next thing you
know it was like the best moment of my
day
and all these guys was like man i always
feel like nobody cares but
these guys care they all care and i care
about them and i just freak
it just it doesn't stick to my ribs like
i wish it would a lot of times so that's
why
i think some people are like man you
chase your tail a lot it's like because
i forget that that that the tail
is there i forget that it how it grew
the tail's wagging the dog yeah right
oh yeah it's like um i don't know it's
just it's
it's all fascinating man the program is
pretty fascinating you know recovery uh
it works so so take us a little bit more
so
so you you have that experience with
your brother kind of and then you get
into it and then you're playing at
michigan state then yeah
and you're doing and so at that point
you're on sarah you're getting into it
yeah yeah yeah like um my brother
got drafted in the first round in the
canadian football league so he went up
to edmonton
over the eskimos yeah oh ricky uh who
played up their quarterback uh warren
moon was just done
he had come went to houston who just
played up there ricky
uh well i played a few years ago six
seven years ago i couldn't tell you six
seven years ago but it was
done again i think was a quarterback
matt dunnigan was the quarterback when
my brother played there
but um and then you know that year he
got drafted was the same year i went to
michigan state
okay because he was already done with
kent state so was that pretty
so was that tough when he left and
you're still there or it was at that
point you were all we sat down and we
made a new plan
dang because it was like all right this
plan is executed
now let's make another plan and then so
we made a general plan
he reached his goals to get him drafted
he obviously wanted to get drafted to
the nfl
but you know wasn't you know i guess
it's a nicer man
they apologize for their sex they could
pick a guy
yeah sorry man here they're like
stepping on a guy's throat
canada some people come across the
street just to apologize to you they
didn't even do anything
hey you ever been to a tim hortons oh
yeah
yeah that's right cake donuts and stuff
like you can get a meal there was like
what you have for dinner eight chocolate
doughnuts aren't those fluffy no they
like cake doughnuts they're good timbits
you know those little timbers
i love going into tim hortons every time
i go people are like what do you like to
see in cannon i'm like tim hortons you
know
they're all a little different right
right right right yeah
oh what's that on the roof a reindeer
maybe what is it
oh that's your step dad trying to do a
breaking and entering
but no matter what the holiday season is
here
and holiday shoppers are buying more
stuff online than ever before
man it's crazy if you're an online
seller
now you might be struggling to keep up
it's a pain in the butt just you know
having to get each order and process it
and oh my god
where are the labels that's why you need
to get your ship
together with shipstation which shipping
carrier should you use
well shipstation is the fastest easiest
and most affordable way to manage and
ship your orders
in just a few clicks you're managing
orders printing out labels and getting
your products out
fast shipstation works no matter where
you're selling
through shopify amazon ebay even
your own website shipstation brings all
your orders into one simple interface
making them easy to manage from any
device even your phone
ship station works with ups usps
fedex even international no wonder
shipstation is the number one choice of
online
sellers and right now this past weekend
listeners can try shipstation for free
for 60 days when you use offer code theo
if you're running a business and you're
managing the orders yourself get some
help
it's free that's right go to
shipstation.com
and use offer code t-h-e-o make sure
your business can meet the demands of
this massive online shopping season that
shipstation.com enter offer code theo
ship station make ship happen well i'll
tell you today i'm wearing a
business shirt or a church shirt they
call it
one unexpected side effect of the year
is it feels like fashion
is gone and i don't know about you but i
don't even know what the trends are
nowadays
i saw somebody the other day wearing a
hazmat suit pressure washing a box of uh
triscuits so what the hell is that
what i'm telling you is do what i do
don't buy for now
buy for forever for timeless pieces that
will last a lifetime of
wear check out farty that's right
farty makes high quality comfortable
clothing for life
sustainably minded designing products
with a thoughtful focus
on fabric every piece is made to last a
lifetime
that's beautiful you could give it give
it to somebody when you died
you died give it to somebody have it at
the funeral a little to go back there
you go there's a sweater fire tee
firety is committed to community in the
environment and all that they do
the company is run by the fire tea
family and they are very hands-on
ensuring everything they do lives up to
their values
the legend collection is legendary check
it out
you want clothes that last enough of
this junk enough
of this rigmarole buying forever
is the smartest way to shop and now is
the smartest time to do it right now you
can get 25
off your next fire to purchase when you
do fireteabrand.com
theo that's firet f-a-h-e-r-t-y
brand dot com slash t-h-e-o for 25
off fire t brand dot com slash theo
um we had a question that came in this
is a question that came in from a young
man right here
about your time at michigan state he had
a kind of a long preamble
for tony is i'm well first of all i grew
up in east lansing so i'm familiar kind
of with the incredible bulk the
folklore the story of the incredible
bulk
um and uh but i was curious
and i know a lot of people are gonna be
asking questions about steroids and
small penis things
and i'm sure um but
what was a what was the academic life of
a 1980s football star like
did you go to class did people do your
work for you
or maybe you were really diligent in
class i
i don't know but i suspected it was
different
from the stereotypical college students
uh
experience that's a great question it is
a great question it's a great question
um so i mean i'll be 100
transparent um i went to class um i
i didn't i didn't graduate i was like 12
credits short of graduating
when i moved to cali after the gator
bowl was our last game and then
i i would have to go through spring
semester and graduate you know
and i already knew i was going to get
drafted okay um
so you're just i just went to cali and
went to move to whittier
trained with my trainer and just it was
balls to the walls for the next six
months
training what was the study like when
were you at school
you know it was um
you know what i guess i'd be lying if i
said there was no favoritism
because there was there wasn't
favoritism favorites was not a good word
there were certain things that were made
just
a little bit more convenient for us
but it's really at the end of the day it
comes down to what you
make it right because if i want it i
mean michigan state is known as a great
agricultural school and great veterinary
school
so it if i really applied myself which i
wish i would have
um like in something like business
administration or you know something
that
that there's fundamentals of business
that will be timeless
right right obviously the internet
changed a lot of that but still
relationships are a fundamental of
business yeah so
but you know i took public relations and
marketing
which is still good even though the
marketing these days is so different
than the marketing would have been in
80s like print marketing and stuff right
right you know or public relations or
whatever
but that also did help me yeah but that
did help me with a lot of the
you know pr stuff with interviews and
just
you know stuff like that so you were
going to class something yeah i mean
we had tutors at our disposal but you
know our like my day would start at 7 00
a.m
and but you know you have to be at
practice at three
and i'd have classes all the way up to
like about an hour and a half before
prac
uh classes all day before practice and
then you'd practice for two hours
and then you'd have to watch film and
then they'd have study hall mandatory
study hall
at the football facility right so they'd
have tutors come in if we wanted them
and there'd be tutors available and then
um
or you could just stay in study hall
like it was mandatory
by the coach and were you a prize pig at
this point were you like one of like the
heroes on the squad
when i when i went there yeah no i was i
was just
one of the guys in this class there was
some studs that came in my class did
y'all ever play against rudy from
that movie no we ain't that old yeah
good
i can't remember who they played notre
dame that was notre dame he played for
notre dame but we played notre dame
every year
yeah but no he's he's he's probably 10
years older
next generation um
so so the academics were not i mean it
wasn't like there was no like
no freebies given right you know there
were some
you i would always have like i'd say one
course a semester that was kind of like
you pretty much if you attended it
you're pretty much gonna pass right
it almost sounds like anybody's college
period i mean i remember going in like
the greek kids always had all the tests
somehow right like that was insane how
the [ __ ] does this girl just because
she's kind of hot
right you know right right rebecca has
the [ __ ] test
you know what i'm saying she's never
done anything but it was crazy you have
like
people really studying and then you
would just go over to somebody's house
and they would have the same it was just
college sometimes was crazy
i got remember getting paid by a coach
one time to write papers for some of the
players even um
so i think there's always been some of
that in school you know just like uh
that
athletes get help yeah they get it but i
think they should because their time is
taken up
with practice too right and so that
being said their time is taken up with
practice
plus how much revenue does that support
bring into that school
so and that's not saying hey look the
other sports don't matter yes they
matter
but a lot of those other sports at that
school or any school wouldn't exist
like no i'm not talking about basketball
i'm talking about yeah i'm not even
gonna say because i don't want to offend
it i'm not gonna say it
yeah i'm not gonna say anything
between titles eight and ten right and
it's like
it's like you know i respect anybody
that wants to compete and do something
that they love to do but totally but the
money comes from that that's how the
where a lot of the rent in michigan
state is football and basketball right
so um which by the way they beat duke
yesterday did they yeah
i didn't see that i saw kentucky lost
last night i think to kansas did um
was there an opportunity for you to play
basketball at some point
[Music]
seriously yeah
they never said hey guy i woulda
what is that hey guy intramural maybe oh
really i wasn't the last guy who picked
an intramural team
okay but no michigan state like they
were i mean magic johnson had just left
there
wow like three four years prior and they
were like stacked and they were
i mean that's big time basketball yeah i
mean they're good they're
i mean you know indiana's big time
basketball too
because at that time was bobby knight
was there oh wow and
the head coach at state now for
basketball was an assistant to judd
heathcote when i was there
so i've got to watch
this coach just you know blossom over
the last
30 years so you get so you go through
michigan state and then you get drafted
and by then you're like a hero that's
when we see like the big pictures of you
that's when we see you like um
you know really kind of put on this
i don't know what was that like like
take me through a little bit of that
like
did you s kind of start that legend of
yourself or was that all kind of media
created i know that sports illustrated
came out like the day before the draft
or a couple days before
yeah or you know one of the famous um
yeah that's right on that's right on
venice beach actually damn dude let me
tell you this bro
if you wanted to uh start an all men's
football team today
on venice beach bro that picture would
get it done i'll tell you that
i'll tell you this half the moon will be
wearing roller skates
but you could like the four skates not
the blaze
rainbow socks rainbow socks we're
talking inline
we're talking inline but out of line you
feel me daddy
um so take i mean
because you like that that image right
there especially for people that are
looking at sports illustrated like
that's the thing that comes in the mail
where it's like okay i didn't know about
this guy
and now i know about this guy and then i
go to the water cooler and i'm talking
about like i've known about this guy
forever
right yeah it was like a phenomenon it
was it was
it really like it was almost overnight
like that
for me it wasn't like any different like
i was like
working my ass off every day to be the
best right i woke up like literally
every day being like
what can i do today to get myself better
and were you doing steroids that whole
time
um when i was at school yeah yeah
and did you feel like um do you did you
ever
i guess did you have the like were you
afraid to probably get off them at that
point i would be afraid to get all
i mean i was just going to math i would
have afraid to get off of them you were
collecting papers from
dudes you were married to the teacher
though
um you know yeah i mean if i had my
preference i would not have got off of
them
but the you know the nfl's testing was
way more
uh sophisticated so was that scary then
you're getting drafted and you
know that like you know it wasn't as
scary
as you might think and this is why
because i've i've
looked back at this in my life and every
time i took steroids and then got like
if i got on for 12 or 16 weeks and then
got off for
uh 12 weeks and got back on i would lose
about
10 15 maximum 20 of my strength
well then you know so every time you
cycle you compound that strength and
keep you keep getting stronger stronger
so when i got drafted i mean if you're
benching close to 600 pounds and you
lose 15 or 20
of your strength you're still pretty
strong yeah and you're still pretty much
stronger than
a lot of the guys in the nfl so really
wasn't that much
of a concern the psychological effect of
steroids are
as well as they work physically the
multiplier on the psychological effect
in my opinion are at least
five to ten fold um like you know that
feeling you're talking about earlier
like when you feel like yeah
yeah and then then you don't have that
feeling yeah right and you're going to
another level
oh that would be to me that's only don't
give me anxiety right now here you say
that like
okay i'm walking into this place and
suddenly like some of the wet
the sword is my sword's different right
and all the expectations
all the [ __ ] talking i did not on
steroids anymore still all the
accusations
i was like you know and i was like i'm
definitely not gonna do steroids because
it's gonna
everybody's gonna be like see told you
so he tested positive right so
but you know what the the thing was like
that there was definitely that was a
spoke in the wheel
but everybody was like no that is the
reason the only reason and it was
perfect for me because it was like
there's so much distraction there was
focusing on steroids i was over here
taking 89 painkillers a day
conning all these pharmacists and
doctors that's crazy
so it took kind of like the thing like
the concentration away from
something they didn't know about because
they kept saying steroids well i was
half in the bag all the time
so at this point this one you start to
realize you probably have some addiction
looking back it's easy to see it but
were you able to see that at the time or
not really
um my fourth year their third or fourth
year there well actually my third year
there i knew it was mainlining
pharmaceutical painkillers that was the
problem when in green bay you mean
yeah damn i knew that was the problem so
i'm just gonna switch to
livestock countries you're getting good
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying like
[Laughter]
like you wake up ready to work you know
you stick that aluminum machine up on
you oh yeah
dude i've had fresh milk right off of
the animal it's not that good i don't
think that's good it's not that good and
it's hot
yeah it's really overrated in like a lot
of the you know old school pictures and
stuff you see but um
yeah uh and we don't have to talk about
sarah i mean
i want to talk about your whole life you
know i just know it's
you know i just know that it's
interesting and it's something that i
could kind of relate to yeah you know
um in the addiction like i never thought
i had a problem with drugs until it
came to the painkillers that's because i
was like
i like when you go through physical
withdrawal whether it's alcohol or
painkillers they're different
types but listen it's pain right it's
not a good comfortable feeling
and you were putting it in your vein
yeah i was mainlining it right there
with and see the mark
oh i could hit that vein right dark a
little basketball
you could tell i was right-handed right
i didn't need a tourniquet yeah
right because it was all veiny anyways
but i knew that that was the problem
that's the rationalization kicked in
right i know it's the main lining that's
killing me
so i'm just gonna switch to oral
painkillers wow well then you're taking
60 70 80 90 a day
and what were you on were some different
things you were on at the time
a lot of the basic stuff you'll hear per
game percocet there was one called
fearing all three that i really liked
if you're in all three i thought it was
a movie yeah right that's uh it's
not the sequel but the third is it
wesley snipes in that
you know if you're in all three how
about this every year jason versus
freddy isn't it
within myself right it was a dark
it was a dark neighborhood up here and
there's some dark alleys boy i tell ya
but there was uh yeah there was
there was like uh if you're enough like
you you probably don't remember this
because it was before the internet there
was something called a pdr
and it stood for physicians desk
reference
and if you'd ever go to your doctor's
office back then they'd have this big
thick it looked like a big old
encyclopedia
well it had every drug made that year
or that was available that year so i
would like this is the lengths i would
go to
to get the narcotics wow i would find
which ones are not
triplicates like triplicate um copies
of a prescription okay now it's all
digital and stuff even though they get
right physical
if it's a triplicate one of those uh
forms goes to the dea okay one goes to
the doctor
and one i think goes to the pharmacy or
something well the trick was to find
something that was like
like a class or like a duplicate okay
because then it only goes to the
pharmacy
and your doctor and the pharmacies all
weren't integrated
so you could like if there was walgreens
on this corner it's not connected to
that walgreens
i mean it might be on paperwork right it
might be at least not already right
right you're right right but that was
the old internet somebody keep coming by
and get all these refills right
and uh wow but yeah so i would look for
the duplicates
but that still had the certain chemicals
that i knew would you know mind-alter
wow so you were in it yeah
and then uh so that that that was a
duplicate
that injection it was used it was mainly
used for women that started labor
um because they didn't want to numb them
too much because they still had to push
yeah but it would give them enough of a
relief to take the edge off the pain so
that was like for somebody like a drug
addict it's
trying to you know it's perfect perfect
yeah go to the bathroom but i'm gonna be
[ __ ] up right
right exactly do um where was your head
at at that point so my ass
[Laughter]
and there's some days sobers on my ass
how much how much what was your ego like
at that point i saw because it's funny i
saw a david letterman interview out
there years and it's
hilarious bro you have so many funny
lines in it
um you like my theo haircut uh yeah i
did i noticed that i knew
i knew you were on your way immediately
this is definitely a sign that you're
going to end up in recovery
[Laughter]
but this interview i thought you were
just so first of all i could feel a
little bit of your nerves just because
what does it have to be like for a guy
like this to be
i mean this is a huge show um and then
to be sitting there and you went toe to
toe with them with a lot of great uh
comedy a lot of great barbs
um he had a lot of great lawns what uh
where was your ego
at during this because i can imagine
that this would get you
probably you know your head would also
start to gain size was that happening
for you or were you just
were you chill i mean where was your
vibe no the ego was starting to get out
of control
and and this was you know i was the
injectable painkillers were just
starting
and i was i was at this time
i was on the tail end of living in
california i lived in cali for nine
months
and that's after the draft this was
after the draft
um before the season started yeah
because i held out until september 5th
oh that's right you're talking about
your contract in this
because we were gonna because tyson's
people contacted
tyson's people contacted my people that
sounds so [ __ ] stupid
but that's how it works right we all get
it
but you know the the cool thing was i
loved letterman growing up i watched him
all the time and then you get this
invite you're going are you freaking
kidding me it's like almost as good as
getting
the invite to be on the show almost as
good almost as good
and because i was like theo who and i
was like i
checked this guy out online before i
answered this email and i started
watching and like four hours later i'm
still watching all these different stuff
and i'm like this guy's like legit
he's like authentic he's no [ __ ]
he's funny and [ __ ]
we're trying and he's over we're trying
our best man you guys are doing it man
i'm telling you
but yeah i i i am really glad that you
uh
that you gave us the opportunity to be
here with you i appreciate it i really
am man um
so yeah because it's just it's
interesting man like uh for one i'm
surprised how easy it is for me to talk
to somebody else that's in recovery
you know like a lot like a lot of that
it's interesting it's like
it's like a non-tangible risk it's not a
it is kind of a respect but it's like i
know you've been through the gutter
and i know you [ __ ] pulled yourself
out of it yeah and i know how you feel
it's funny
it's like i know how you feel in places
where i can't even describe it kind of
you know right right yeah and it's
especially interesting because to have
those feelings but also to be such a big
guy like when did that kind of come to a
head for you because it's
like some of those feelings it's like
damn i feel like such a [ __ ]
you know um and no offense to [ __ ]
you know no but if someone hasn't been a
[ __ ] in their life at some point they
have lived in a cave
sorry if if you haven't failed in life
okay i mean we get to fail on the front
page yeah
right so yeah i mean i brought it upon
myself i think accountability
um did you start to feel like um
so take me out on the road out of the
out of the nfl taking on that some of
that road
the first time out yeah so for your
contract with
the packers was uh four year 4.4 million
dollar contract that was the first
offensive lineman
to get i need to water you have one of
yours i got caught okay cool um
i think i got a so i was the first
offensive lineman ever
in the nfl to make a seven figure
average salary per year without ever
playing a play
so you know that's going to kind of rub
some people wrong especially offensive
lineman
but the smart offensive lineman were
like
no this is going to help us right
because the next year there was like 27
28 guys that made over
that were in the league already and they
deserved it
so i went in with the kind of attitude
of this is a short-lived career
and it could be one play and you're done
like you could blow your knee out never
come back from
it i mean probably one of the greatest
athletes ever in my opinion is bo
jackson
and i think the amount of torque that
that guy had and strength in his body is
what kind of hurt his hip
like i i believe that right it's almost
too much yeah it's almost too much
right because the guy was like just i
mean baseball he was an all-star and
in in football he was a an all-pro yeah
i mean he was unprecedented did you play
it around the same time as him or no
uh he was like three four years older
than me
okay um herschel was like
in that like kind of like you could have
that discussion with hershey walker too
he's like ridiculously like athletic
he still looks like yeah yeah and he's i
mean he's the real deal
you know he's a great guy and um like
for me
like my class my draft class like you
know for the first five guys are in the
hall of fame
you bring that up nick please you know
dion like dion sanders right
i've never seen anything like that on
the field yeah that guy didn't run
across he glided across the loaded
i mean it was ridiculous what he did and
um
you know he's a he was a pleasure to
watch is it wild to see your name when
you look at this tony um not anymore
it's right it's kind of like you know
it's like i i i you know listen
wow look i feel why not yeah look at
those guys though i mean unfortunately
you know derek thomas had that accident
that was heartbreaking yeah
god um but you know bert grossman
from the chargers i had done um his
radio show
uh from san diego like maybe a month ago
um there's some like steve hotwater yeah
you remember when atwater hit
um oh the guy from kansas city uh the
nightmare the nigerian nightmare
i don't know if i remember when he hit a
guy from uh san francisco one time
um in this well the guy that uh what was
this oh
uh christian yeah and that from that hit
that guy's career was never the same
because he was running people over like
a train
and when he hit that guy it was one i
mean to this day one of the best hits
i've ever seen
and you know atwater was taken what late
in the first round
right watch this and christian nikoi was
like 250 266
unbelievable man and he knocked him
backwards at full speed
wow i'll tell you what i got a lot of
respect for that
those broncos were fun to watch i got a
lot of respect for that um
so what what so take so take me uh take
me out of the end of that so you get
into you go into recovery in a real
world
no well yeah so i get you know pretty
much
not officially kicked out of the league
but kind of like green bay's like after
the
contract was over after four years
they're like we're not going to resign
you
we don't we don't want your services and
they were professional about it
right and of course at that time i was
like well i don't want to play for you
guys it's your fault anyways that my
career screwed up
my life's good it's not my fault right i
was all about it all the time
all the time it was nick's fault totally
i got
so it was you know it was so that
you know so i get that call in january
and
february i got the call that my brother
uh had passed
and then so it was like god things can't
get worse it's like oh man don't ever
say that
because things just got worse they got
worse and i knew that
i mean i knew that my nfl career
with the packers was a definite bust
because of the my addiction problem
and just my you know not being capable
of
doing what i could do before i just
wasn't capable i don't think i could
have worked at a
anywhere 7-eleven and that's not dissing
7-eleven or anything it's just
i wasn't responsible enough to show up
and for three years after that that was
out of the league
i it just get darker and darker and
darker and more and more and more
painkillers and where were you living at
that time i was in michigan maple city
michigan which is right by traverse city
wow i can imagine it gets pretty dark if
you start just killing pain over in
michigan after a while
yeah michigan is beautiful though well
michigan is a great place i just imagine
like in those long winters and those
place
you know what i'm saying like i imagine
that coming around it was a long summer
it was a long spring it was a long fall
everything was
everything was like why do these bad
things keep happening to me
it couldn't be me could it and you were
on a lot of painkillers huh yeah
and were you just like spending days in
bed were you just like doing i mean
are you partying were you having no i
was uh
i wasn't much for like going out to
party like
i i was like kind of like a loner drink
i was married and stuff you know and
we had a daughter our first daughter and
um it was it was like
isolated drinking i guess drinking and
drugging would be the isolated i think
would be the best
way to describe it i hated people yeah
you know because just guys they're gonna
interrupt my buzz
and i know i want my buzz perfect
and they're i've been watching this
white bronco go down to 405
and i'm in michigan i'm going can you
believe this [ __ ] is happening am i
being messed up or is this [ __ ] really
happening like and
you know it was it was like a it was
like
i mean you're conscious you know what's
going on but it's a blur it's like a
blur yeah
yeah being being messed up that kind of
sounds a blur especially it feels like
with pain
with painkillers i never got into
painkillers but the couple times i did
my friend got arrested and i just woke
up in my car right
you know and so it affects people
definitely too right like for me like
really a painkiller is a downer it's a
depressant as is alcohol
but for me when i would take a downer
like painkiller like opiate i would get
high
like like energy high and i'd be like
let's go
to the mall right and walk around the
food court and get something from every
place
um such an offensive lineman
[Laughter]
not much has changed there but
but it it was it was weird but then you
know that darkness sets in
yeah it's not good it's uh when the
darkness gets that dark
you either get sober or you die or you
die from it yeah or
an or a symptom from it whether you take
your own life whether you
your liver goes whether your heart goes
whether all the side effects
what do you think right now i mean you
know we had this guy morgan wallin on
the podcast last week he's a country
musician and we talked briefly about
the side effects of this all this
lockdowning and the
inability of like i'm going to meet with
with a new sponsor later today actually
to go over to start doing the step work
again
and we're trying to find a place to meet
and it's like we can't even
meet anywhere like we have to meet at
one of our houses which is fine but
if you're if you're just getting into
trying doing the steps or something like
if somebody's like hey come over to my
house and you've never even met them
right like that can be
you know some guys won't go do that
right and it just makes me like all the
meat
you know so many of the meeting rooms
even though some are still going on the
dl but like a lot of them being closed
and
i just i i i feel like we're going to
lose more people from
the fallout of addiction problems than
we ever are from
this silly disease or whatever and
that's just from addiction
what about just mental illness right
like like the suicides
i saw you know a report i don't know
what to believe anymore what i see right
now
it's like so warped one way or the other
but numbers are numbers facts are facts
and like
there's a four-fold numbers are up in
this one
state of teenage suicides from last year
to this year
and it's like what's the only difference
the lockdown right yeah and not no
nobody in school and it's like
kids that were on the fence with maybe
depression or with
you know kind of trying to figure out
still who they are it only took me like
40 years but
i'm still trying to figure it out but
we're literally
as long as we're learning right as long
as we're trying to learn um
so you know a lot of those people went
on the fence the other way and just
took themselves out because they felt it
was it was
you know easier yeah and it is easier
it's the easy way out
it's you know and it's that's you know
no disrespect
just to you know people that are related
that has had somebody do that to
themselves because it's it's got to be a
horrible feeling i mean i've had friends
that have done it and i and i just like
my heart just bleeds for him um because
it's like
i mean how bad does it have to get to do
that
and it you know it's like well it did
get that bad you know for me
it got that bad yeah and others i've had
some moments over the years
yeah you just isolate enough or you feel
like nobody cares even though they do
but
yeah the worst conversation to have is
with yourself in your head
it's like it's like it's a bad
conversation it's a bad conversation
about
it's like i gotta run it by a lot of
people yeah you know and
not there's like three or four people
that i like trust my life with
and i'll just be like what do you think
of this am i out of line here is my
is my ego get into this or is am i
being selfish with this or is this an
opportunity to take advantage of
and you know because
a lot of times my perspective is
different i grew up like i think
your environment the way you grow up
affects your perspective on life and
your life's experiences
um that's like easy that's obvious so
that's why i need
other people's perspectives if if if
people were to raise their kids today
say the way i was raised
they'd be in jail right for child abuse
right or like you know you got slapped
or whatever
i only had to get hit well slapped in my
face twice
before you pancake block someone no it
was once i i was like oh before you got
together before i was like
after after the second time i was like
crystal clear i understand
if you say don't do this i won't that's
the rule yeah and
and i was like you know six seven years
old and it was like
and and you know what i'm glad that it
was that way for me
because i don't want to be babied right
i don't want to be
you know i don't want to do pillow
fights it's funny because you say baby i
and sometimes i feel like honestly what
i feel like sometimes is a baby i'm like
i'm
like i'm a baby that never got certain
things when i was a baby probably so
[ __ ] sometimes i still act like a
baby
but then i'm the only person there it's
like i'm the baby and i'm the person
[ __ ]
reaching it that has to reach into the
crib to [ __ ] help myself you know
so thankfully over time i start to
realize that i need to be
more at least i know i'm capable after a
few minutes of being the baby
or getting
right um so when did so we kind of gone
through like a little bit of like your
journey so tell me like
like when did you start to get like a
new perspective kind of march
23rd and 95 walked into that treatment
center
and i remember thinking to myself like i
could picture that
that stainless steel door like
industrial door
and thinking to myself the fun's over
yeah but i was like i'd rather be boring
and
sober than miserable and drunk or
an alcoholic life and
11 days later i stayed in that treatment
for 17 days at
day 11 i started laughing again
and uh
my gut hurt from laughing that day wow
and i was like i forgot about that you
noticed it i forgot about that feeling
that powerful
and i was like i don't know what's
happening but i'm digging my claws into
it
and i've been laughing ever since damn
even on the tragic days there's been
some kind of laughter even if it's been
internal
like amusement in my own head like is
you know like we make fun of our poke
fun of ourselves
oh yeah i don't have to sit and laugh
out loud to be
you know put things in perspective but
you know even on days
where my mom died three years or three
and a half years ago was like a hard day
for me and
and and and really it was like the
harder year after was harder for me than
that week that
you know that she had died and stuff she
always have stuff to do that week
yeah i kick into like you know i gotta
get things done there's responsibilities
i gotta you know make sure things are
right
and then once you sit you know that
passes and then you sink in and you're
not buying that ticket to go see mom in
november
like to see her for christmas because
you're like mom ain't there i'm
gone that's when you're like [ __ ] that's
heavy
um so you so you went in there you
started to get better
yeah yeah like day 11 started laughing
again and then
yeah there's little things man you
notice i i remember
having a thought that made me laugh i
remember just driving one time
and um and i've struggled in and out
over my five years in recovery but i've
never given up on
on the program or or trying to uh
you know i haven't given up on that path
yet in my life um
and i'm trying it new now you know
trying it again um
but i remember yeah a time when i
just was driving down the road and i
laughed just by myself and i was like
[ __ ] i haven't done that in months
just the little things that were like um
that you just came or just like i
remember i woke up in the middle of the
night one night and i didn't have a
thought in my head
and it was like jesus christ this is so
nice isn't that nice
the noise is not there yeah just like
especially for someone like you
yeah well it's like somebody started
like somebody left something plugged in
that's rattling like
40 years ago and it's rattling all that
and i can't
find it put a twist tie around that
thing yeah
something um so you had a second
opportunity with the nfl
yeah okay which i was very lucky to get
because i burned all my bridges i was i
was thorough
i burned them all i was like i'm not
gonna burn one or two i'm gonna fry them
all
because it's all their fault couldn't be
my fault
and so you know there was a huge
paradigm shift
once i left sobriety it literally almost
went to
what's for it went from what's in it for
me to
what can i pack into life what can i
pack into how can i make things right
that i wronged and then after i make
some of those things right because some
of you can't
then how am i going to live and
am i going to be adding on a daily basis
to life and participating or am i going
to be sucking and conning people like
sucking out of life and conning stuff
out of people and
you know because then it's like it's
like that you know you've i'm sure
you've heard that analogy of the so
the drunk horse thief that you get sober
you get it
you know if you get a of a drunk horse
thief that steals horses and you sober
them up what do you have
you have a sober horse sleeping still
steals he's got to change
he's got to change and so i knew that
okay
the chemical part was changed but now i
had to change
and that paradigm shift happened kind of
naturally
just from the removal of chemical of
what's in it for me to
holy [ __ ] like i did some [ __ ] up
stuff and i wronged some people
right and so i you know made those
amends over
you know most of those amends were done
over the first two years and then
the one of the bigger ones with my dad
um wasn't done until the four year mark
but it was done and it was it was you
know necessary it was what was that like
well you know what it was this it was
the one that obviously scared me the
most it was
had the most fear and i was in
indianapolis he was in canada
and um like i was
four years sober and a guy walked in to
a regular meeting i went to a 12-12
meeting
and he was like almost 20 years sober
and a regular guy that i knew
and he had said that his dad had passed
away that day
and uh and then he talked about how he
never made amends to his dad and i was
like
holy [ __ ] i was like louisville slugger
came out again
damn out that next day i was on the
phone with my dad i was like
for christmas i'd like to come up and
see ya
you know and uh and he was like yeah so
i went out like that was towards the end
of the season so when the season was
over
um i drove up to canada and made amends
to him
and uh it was it was it's
you know it's like i i was lucky to be
surrounded by good sobriety
guys that were very good in sobriety and
that were
and i chose a sponsor that would not
baby me i don't want to be babied
um and
he said when you make amends you look at
the person in the eye and you tell them
you were wrong
for the way you acted or what you said
or what you did
you don't say i'm sorry because you know
you
how many times have we said i'm sorry
for this and when we're all messed up
right i'm sorry
we're always apologizing right yeah it's
like no
he literally said i was wrong for acting
that way while i was drinking or
drugging or whatever and you know i'm
here to
you know acknowledge it and even if they
played
a part in it it's not about that yeah
you're there for
to make your part right and it's crazy
how people don't realize that that is
the real
key to a lot of it you know is setting
yourself free even though it feels like
you're letting them off the hook
well you're getting your own here's the
thing there's a huge
caveat in there that is huge the that i
know
i've seen people do this and it's like i
just want to like punch them in the face
and it's like they make the amends
for them you know they do it right the
amends at the expense of that other
person yeah it's gonna hurt that other
person
more re hashing that up or whatever the
situation is
it's there are some things better just
left alone yeah
and just let your life the way you live
be the example and if that person ever
approaches you
or if you just get in a situation where
it feels right to be like hey man you
know about you know
um you know about the past or whatever
but there were ones most of my amens
were
literally like where i planned them and
i
you know talked to the person or
communicated and said hey you know i'd
like to
meet up just talk to you about some
stuff and um
so they were you know mostly like that
but to look your dad in the eye and say
i was wrong for all these it was
wow be powerful it was powerful had you
been like ashamed of your dad or
something have you been like or
scared to death were you there i was
like 6 6 3
25 you know strong [ __ ] second time in
the nfl
and that should put a lot of things in
perspective for people that don't
understand addiction
that how emotions can run your life and
how fear can run your life
and how just because you're being strong
doesn't mean you're not scared yeah
you know people have assumptions that
i mean i've it's been it's just i've
there's just been some humorous things
i'm sure
as you have had in your life where
people have this assumption of what
a comedian how they live what they drive
what this you know they live in this 10
million dollar however
it's like yeah it's like you know it's
it's
it's interesting to me to observe that
as life has gone on
but um i forgot what the [ __ ] we were
talking about the amount
yeah i've had concussions yeah [ __ ] i
don't know
i'm not that smart i never was because
but i work with a guy who's [ __ ] got
enough concussions for all of us
[Laughter]
but yeah it's uh well the thing about
putting things in perspective that
look my fear is the same fear that
soccer mom fear has
right it's like just because
you know some people will say to me you
know like
when i played and and even sometimes now
or they might say it you know if it's
just comes up in
conversation about
you know well i mean i know you wouldn't
be if you know that wouldn't mess with
you because i mean you know you could
you could handle a situation like that
and i'm thinking of myself and i would
literally will
be transparent i'll be like how do you
know yeah and they they're
still not getting it and i'm like and
then i would just share a story with
them
that is almost the semantics are
different the story is identical
the situations are different but it's
identical and it's like you know i was
scared to death
this story i shared with you about my
dad it's like
would you like i'm sure there was people
going what do you mean you were scared
of your dad
your dad will always be your dad yeah no
matter what
and your mom will always be your mom and
you know
it's like your bigger brother will
always be your bigger brother or younger
brother or younger sister whatever it's
like
it's kind of like we get these certain
roles and it's like
you know dad will always be alpha no i
don't care if i'm 10 times stronger than
him it'll always be the alpha
family yeah yeah i think there's
probably some like uh
code that's within some of our law yeah
we got a question right here that came
in from somebody that has a
iphone and i actually had one too how
often when people hear your name
do uh they mix your story up with todd
marinovich
does that ever happen you know hardly
ever because yeah he was just the
problem yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then
a little bit younger than me but i i
tell you what i do get a lot of
is when people will hear my name and
they'll be like
they'll be like are you the you know
yeah and they'd be like okay
but that makes sense carry on that's
your name now
am i supposed to fake it that's true i
thought maybe you were the guy that died
that fought rocky for a second
oh but then you know i've made some
i don't know a lot here's a young fella
that has a question right here
he's probably trying to buy some wind
straw i bet
a little bloated what up theo what up
tony a big fan from the university of
alabama represent from tuscaloosa
on a side note theo we're gonna beat
lsu's ass this weekend you probably will
my question for tony is as a former
offensive lineman myself
what was the best game as far as
knockdowns or pancakes whatever you want
to call them that you ever had
and how many did you have game game game
bro what do you think there tony
there was there a game that stands out
really
um i'd yeah there's one because i
i like wanted to go out and torture the
person or the team
or the school that i didn't like and it
was that other school
in michigan i don't know what their name
is but yeah there's only one school in
michigan
right no that's no disrespect to u of m
i mean
they're a great institution but
obviously a huge
interstate rivalry and at that time they
were like
constantly winning going the rose bowl
beauchem beckler iconic
i mean so much respect for that guy um
but you know i i probably had games
where i had more pancakes or
otfs we used to call them off the film
um where you drive a guy so far off the
like that you don't even see him on the
film
so i had like probably like some games
or
more but there was a certain michigan
game that we had
where probably maybe had 13 or 14
pancakes wow
but it's because it was michigan it was
sweeter
yeah right and um
yeah it's like i it was interesting like
when i look back and i don't think i'm
sadistic
but i didn't play to make friends
and i didn't play to help you up if you
were my opponent
i didn't play dirty um there'll be
people that say well you cheated
okay and and that's legit but i didn't
you know
after after michigan state you know it's
like
i didn't take any steroids but yeah at
school i mean
yeah did i take steroids was it yeah did
i cheat yeah i did
i was wrong for doing it and i don't
recommend that anybody does it
um but that drive for
for like you know your etiquette and
stuff i mean what's
in your blood and what's in your heart
and your what's in your behavior can
be different things yeah and you don't
you know there's people that
especially guys that i'm talking that
are like well yeah but he took steroids
and it's like okay well
yeah why didn't you play in the nfl
right why didn't you become all-american
why didn't you do all these things all
you had to do was take steroids
yeah right it's like it's like you don't
just take steroids sit around and get
jacked yeah everybody every guy would be
jacked and have abs
right you have to put in the work with
it right right and my work was
relentless
because of walking home from snowstorms
yeah
because of the head coach i had because
the guy who recruited me nick saban
they were all relentless about work
ethic and
the way i grew up parents were
immigrants they like literally
escaped put their lives on the line out
of a communist country in the 50s wow
so i'm like thinking to myself i'm
laying there on the field
at camp sober in indianapolis my second
year there
and it's hot as [ __ ] in july humid
and like just beating up with sweat
during stretch
right you still got two hour practice to
go and kind of feeling sorry for myself
and like
you know and then i started thinking
about a story my mom told me or
something
where her mom pulls her out of third
grade back in the old country in europe
and
it was croatia but it was at that time
yugoslavia
pulled her out of third grade class
and said the guy that was taking care of
our sheep in the mountains
has bailed on us so here's a wooden
staff i need you to go take care of the
sheep
and keep the wolves off of them
damn that's social studies right so good
so when i
i would start thinking of those stories
and i'd be like
whiny ass i know you feeling sorry and
you're getting paid seven figures
and you're bitching about it of course
this was all internalized you know my
self-discussion in my head and it helps
put things in perspective
and it's not tricking yourself it's
legit perspective right
like that happened in 55 that wasn't
that long ago
yeah yeah we've got i mean it's even i
think about it during this pandemic it's
like we're all kind of stuck but then
we're all stuck with our machines and
our
you know trim and our manscaping our
penises or whatever everybody's doing
doing that way before the panda game
i was ahead of the game you might have
been ahead of the game there
but you know what the pandemic for me
personally
has been awesome yeah because like i
i've started to realize i really like
psychology
and like the study of just observation
of people and how they act in human
behavior
and including my own and
it was a fantastic year to do that yeah
like with the toilet paper phenomenon
yeah plus
there was a ton of things i had on the
back burner
that i was gonna eventually get to like
when i had a lull in photography or i
had a lull in something with work
i would get to this and so now there was
a lull right
so now i was like okay well hey i can do
these
projects i had on the back burner
because i did because it was possible
yeah so now i've got those projects
going
and so you know for me
personally it's been a great year and
and and not so
not as much great monetarily as it's
been learning
it's been freaking phenomenal it's a
good attitude man
yeah we talk about perspective and stuff
in here a lot and not battle it every
every week and every day um a lot of
what you're doing now is photography
right
yes did i answer that guy's question
that man said he said
your best game yeah michigan oh yeah
yeah it was michigan yeah it was
and what was saban like at that time you
know he was do you remember him finally
or no yeah
yeah i mean i babysit his kids oh damn
yeah
um i would say nick was uh oh yeah
i behaved and i'd be alarmed if you
freaking bottle-fed me dude i would
be alarmed nick was uh
awesome nick is the same guy i mean he's
a different guy today but he was pretty
much the core of him was
exactly what he is what you see now he
was about fundamentals
discipline keeping things simple
removing distractions and do your
job you'd be you should go talk with
jocko willing he'd be great on jacob's
podcast tom
what to put you guys together man he you
guys yeah i'm a huge fan of his yeah
he's
good he's legit i got his books and
stuff yeah he's um
he's definitely when i think about
giving up which is a couple times a day
usually at least one of those times i
won't
because yeah you and me both um
yeah saban's unbel it's just it's
unprecedented in almost what he's done
he was a db coach when he recruited me
and ohio was his area
so you weren't even on his on his docket
no he was there
looking at another guy who was one of
the stars on our team and
then he said to our head coach at the
high school who he knew
it's like who's that guy and he told him
and everything he goes well
you know we want to talk to him and they
watch film and stuff and then he they
offered me a scholarship and
on i remember sitting with nick and
nick was the same i mean he's the same
he's a phenomenal
human being the guy is like a first
class human being
i mean and terry his wife terry um
they're great people and uh
i was so lucky to be surrounded by some
of these people
and even all the mistakes i made i was
so lucky to be surrounded amazing and
then to watch
nick go from this db coach to
possibly being one of the greatest ever
college football coaches yeah and then
when he went to alabama it was like oh
you know i'm going to
like knock bear bryant to the side come
on now
there's like a hug right now it's like
no that could be
argued that could be argued because he
did it at lsu
yeah yeah you know there's a lot of
michigan state people that hate him
because he left michigan state
as he was a head coach at michigan state
when he left for lsu but
it's like it's like look man it's a
business yeah it's like
it's funny how your dream sometimes when
they interact with business how they
don't
you wish they would go a certain way or
be a certain way but then sometimes the
gifts you still get your
you still get your dreams it's just not
exactly how you would expect
um looking back do you feel like uh
do you feel like you did the best that
you could have playing football do you
feel like
what you did was what you were gonna do
that was it yeah i held nothing back
yeah i held nothing back at michigan
state
um it's like it's almost
like oxymoron to say i held nothing back
in green bay i held nothing back
drinking and drugging
yeah but i just wasn't capable of
giving them everything that you know
that they had saw on film but then when
i got sober i got the chance to go to
indy and
i was like i literally treated
every day like um like literally like
life and death
wow like if i don't do this today
i will die and there was times where
do what you mean the work right
and and not just the time the work at
work
during the time because you can put in a
bunch of time
and spin your wheels or you can put in
the time and
keep moving forward even if it's that
small increments because it adds up
yeah um do you still
uh you speak on on recovery and stuff
these days
i speak on recovery um adversity
and uh just a lot on you know thinking
you know like
kind of like there's a talk i give when
i speak public do public
speaks uh which kind of slowed down
after the
pandemic um about and the talk is titled
uh why not me yeah and then it's got
like it's through a four description for
the people that book
people to speak on what i talk about and
you know i've always asked myself why
not me
be the one to go from canada
and i was like 11 years old when i made
that decision like i want to play in the
nfl
yeah living the dream you really got to
live out your dreams and i was like why
not me
right like why like seriously why not
somebody's going to win the
the um powerball right so why not me
well
okay we got to take some action you got
to buy a ticket right so at least you
got to have skin in the game
right if you don't buy a ticket you're
not serious right right
at least you're trying right you're
going to see your sponsor
you're moving you know one thing you're
moving forward
whether that's the right sponsor or not
you're looking and seeking
for right making yourself better yeah
so that has to be that has to be
acknowledged
it has to be acknowledged well i think
those are the things that build up
little bits of esteem inside of yourself
you're like okay i'm making this choice
i'm this is what i'm going to do you
know it's like whether it goes
well or not right then you are you
already win a little bit because you're
like i'm i'm making this
effort yeah you know that's such the
hard part sometimes is just
you know sharing or raising your hand or
yeah i struggle with it too
yeah it's hard it's crazy sometimes i'll
be in a meeting and i'll
everything in my brain will be like just
share just tell what's going on and i
won't you know i think you
like i think when you do like i think
i'm gonna be honest with you i've
watched a lot of your stuff in the last
couple weeks and
i'm like [ __ ] you know like this guy's
described a lot of my life like so like
it's like
there's so many common things but the
state i
like the least and the whole union is
louisiana yeah i just
it's just one of those states that i've
gone there like three or four times
to play the saints and it's always been
smoggy and smelly yeah so
like that's my impression of louisiana
there's so much tradition there and like
stuff and like
culture and stuff that i you know like i
know about but i really don't know about
right and it's like it's it's it's not a
disrespect to the beat it was just kind
of like
every time i've gone there it's kind of
been dirty and smelly yeah some of you
get those experiences in places
so it's like you know and but i'm sure
there's people like you know you live in
the desert in arizona it's like
you know yeah they got a lot of uh
serpents out there yeah and scorpions
and
uh people have divorcees
oh they stick like a sword oh my god
they're red flags walking around
all they need is a sickle and a hammer
uh yeah connection is so key man it's
crazy our connection breaks down the
different things that we
well you know like crazy the other
things that we keep this apart
yeah the other day you had said
something
when you do your like uh solo podcast
you do like a lot of talking about
what's going on and stuff and you talked
about
you had said something i was like i can
[ __ ] relate to that [ __ ] there
i pulled into a donut shop and i started
crying oh wow didn't get out of my
vehicle
wasn't touching myself yeah no no when i
was listening to you i was watching it
on the youtube [ __ ] i
feel like you're like wait a second but
you know and then you know
right right and i'm like yeah i know
that feeling
and it's like you know you think like
like you shared it it's real it's
transparent yeah but you don't know how
that affects other people
right because i was like oh [ __ ] i know
that feeling it may not have been a
donut shop
might have been a denny's right that i
pulled into or just might have been an
empty parking lot
that i pulled into and started feeling
sorry for myself if that was the case
for me or whatever the case was
and then you know i love the fact that
you can laugh at yourself because you
crack a joke
while you're doing it and you do it
without laughing can you say well i was
kind but i wasn't touching myself
yeah you know i'm glad i wasn't there
because the people walking you get
arrested for that
well yeah now you're right you get a
long john with cream in it yeah
that's you that's the original tim
hortons right there dude to some guy
masturbating
that's crazy man yeah i was just having
a day man i just had a weird morning it
was just kind of lonesome when i went
there and then my brother's talking to
me
and my brother's been doing this thing
recently like when we're on the phone if
i'm talking about
like uh how i'm feeling or just
something that's going on like he'll be
like oh if you need me to stay on the
phone with you
after we're done talking i'll just sit
here with you you know and
i won't say anything and you don't have
to say anything right
and he's like i'll just sit here with
you that's pretty cool you know and man
it just like
that's pretty cool i mean that's it was
crazy because i just never had anybody
say hey you know no matter what you're
feeling or thinking right now
it's okay i'm just gonna be here with
you right and you don't have to say
anything and i don't have to say
anything
and i and i'm just here for you and man
it just it's
powerful oh it just like it just it
it gets uncontrollable i'm just like man
that's powerful you know uh
that's real [ __ ] it's not it's like
that's authentic real stuff
and you find out who the real who who's
in your who's loyal to you
yeah like and there's there's different
levels i guess of loyalty
different degrees of loyalty but like
when it comes to life and death i'm
talking yeah that's the only loyalty i
want i'm talking about is like i'll be
in your corner even if you're wrong yeah
like that's the kind of loyalty i'm
looking for and
i have less than in my at 54 years old i
have less
than that on you know on one hand like
less than five people
less than four people well it's it's
interesting because the
the one of the remarkable things about
it for me sometimes is that
i think some of my uh
reality and the a little bit of the pain
that comes with it is that i don't know
if i'm ever that for anyone
and so someone is told realization i
just shared with you about the donut
thing and it wasn't it was a funny thing
oh that's interesting and i'm sure
people were like well that was like out
of left field
but here i am at 20 almost 26 years
silver going
like it made me stop it stopped me in my
tracks yeah so i was doing [ __ ] around
the where i live
i was doing something right and i had
your podcast on and i was listening to
it
and i was like oh [ __ ] i was like lump
in my throat i was like
i know exactly what that feels like yeah
so you never know what we say
and we may think it's something like
minutia that doesn't
important um but it'll affect people
yeah and it may help somebody
that's on the fence say you know what if
if that jackass
tony can do it i can do it like i can
get sober
i can at least try and you know what
there's a lot of paths to sobriety
the 12 steps aren't the only way it was
the way that worked for me
yeah and i don't question it and i back
it up
and i'll help any i'll help somebody if
they think
you know if they think having a crystal
in front of them or something that's not
crystal meth
a sedona crystal oh yeah if they think
that's gonna get them sober
okay so be it it's like all right look
if you're trying to improve your life
and if you don't drink
and it's like well you can't be you know
dropping acid
around a crystal trying not to drink
because well that's kind of you know
you're
yeah you got to give something into the
program that's the thing about it
you know it's like you just you have to
give you have to give up something
that's the only reason there is any
value to it to you
um and especially when you're somebody
who has always taken just for yourself
to have to give something up that's a
really hard thing to do
it is uh to really give it up and say
you can't you're not gonna do it you
know so then i want something in return
so that activates a part of me that's
gonna really seek out to probably get
better
because i'll be damned if i'm going to
give something and not get something
right
because that's the way that i felt
growing up like um
like if somebody cared about me that
they it was a give and get situation
like
it was all transactional right you know
even if it really wasn't right it may
have been
right right right but that's how it
registered inside of me you know
in the cash register inside of my heart
or whatever that's how it registered
right it was a transaction
and that's not quite like that feeling
when you freely give selflessly
yeah and expect nothing in return now if
something does come back in return so be
it but if
you don't expect anything you're good
yeah it's like
there was times that there were times
and i noticed this
after it happened and this would be
years a couple
you know more than five years ago i
would on thanksgiving sometimes or if it
was christmas or whatever
i would just show up at the phoenix
salvation army downtown
and i'd be like um i've got four hours
what do you need me to do like i can put
meals on the table for
uh the people i can wash dishes i can
bus tables i can do whatever take
garbages out do a spinal adjustment
whatever
you probably could we need you to crack
people's backs over here by the by the
uh about the stuff pancake this guy
you know it's like so you show up and
you do that right
and then it's the humanly right it's a
good thing to do if you have
if you know yeah if that's something
that
motivates you so when i've i've done
that before
and then i've shared it
on social media like maybe a picture and
not bragging just
shared like uh you know i was lucky to
be able to do this today right then i've
done that
and not shared it on social media and
just shared it with some friends
and then i've done that and not shared
it with anybody
[Music]
and it's funny because when i don't
share that with anybody and i just go do
it
i get the most out of it wow it's kind
of like
that when doing the right thing and
doing the stuff when people aren't
watching
it's like you still do the right thing
so it's like
as much as i i want to say well it's my
ego that wants other people to know look
at the good stuff i'm doing
right even if i just tell my close
circle
still part of it the way i don't think
that and and you know people that do
that there's nothing wrong with that
no but i kind of looked at all three of
those situations and i found that i got
the most
out of it because i knew you know
i believe in god so i knew god knew
right i knew
and i was just trying to be of service
to god's kids yeah who were
and those people the only difference
between the people those people and me
when i was drinking was time because it
was only a matter of time before i was
gonna
be at that table with them if i was
lucky to be at that table with them i
was
dead yeah man it's interesting to hear
that especially in a day where we live
in such a place where we want to share
things and how we do it and how our
communication is
you know our mouths or our phones now
it's like that's
um it's interesting man but it's a nice
reminder
you know it's a nice reminder of uh
especially going into the holiday season
man yeah
um i gotta get some photos taken can can
you take me to tony's pictures
real quick please nick um
nick forgot his charger at home that's
okay nick's running we're gonna finish
up quick
seven percent that's how nick always is
i got one right behind me
nick's always on about a seven percent
man but he's but he the other 93
he spent it he definitely spent it
getting his job done um
it's not because he just showed up was
you know he spent it right
he spent it wisely wow this is awesome
man so you got into this photography how
did
tell me take me through that man you
know the the big catalyst was
dang the s-i cover that's a big catalyst
right you're right
i'm catalog
you're in ketosis right now ladies yeah
this is interesting
yeah it's like a lot of it's compositing
so i think uh we'll have a plan we'll
take a
picture of the person's studio and then
um
whatever the plan is we'll uh
you know i'll add the composite and
usually i try to make nine
any composite i do i try to make the
picture like the background picture the
picture i took
whether it was a ship rock or whatever
like oh i see you're saying she'll take
a actual photo of a person and then put
it on another photo of uh
that i took obviously right right
interesting
this one like that one this is cool like
how many that thing got a ton of likes
i i believe this is the one that got a
ton of likes but here's the funny thing
that was 120 weeks ago okay so
79 000 views okay i got home
and i saw this clouds like that like
they were moving that's time lapse right
there the shot taken every say three or
four seconds five seconds
and i took my camera and literally all i
did was i put it on top of my jeep
no tripod i just put on top of my jeep
kind of tried to make it as level as
possible
set the timer to record and i had set
and my camera was like a
decent camera it's like five or six
thousand bucks so i was like well i
gotta hang out i'm like
just like walk away from the jeep i'm
not in the middle of a desert
where you can walk away from the jeep
and uh and yeah that thing ended up
getting a ton of views and it's like one
it was one of the
most simple and unexpected photos you
know and like that you can see the
before and after there that
of the gentleman with the white tank on
you know it's like that's
like that when you see the final shot or
that's like the behind the scenes shot
and then you see the final shot
oh it's interesting and it's like a lot
of people will say well
i never thought it would look like that
and yeah and a lot of times the
person can't picture what i'm picturing
because i have an idea and
we try to get on the same page with a
lot of stuff like that one of the milky
way there
yeah that was uh i was looking at the
other one oh yeah yeah you're looking at
the milky way
[Laughter]
i was looking at this horrenus right
sorry and that's out of line and i'm
sorry too
no it ain't yeah you're right because
that's a planet yeah it is
well yeah as you were talking about yeah
yeah so you know they see the milky way
coming out
wow so that was at goblin valley and
what is that lasers right there what
does that look like those are uh
actually those are some of them are
shooting stars but most of them are
planes
wow most of them are planes you can tell
the difference between a shooting star
and a plane
by certain things those are planes right
there that's a dope dude
isn't that cool yeah that's crazy that's
in the middle of freaking nowhere that's
really really cool and i love it
dude i'll let let's do some pictures
sometime when i get out of here that'd
be super cool to get something neat
i think i think get something outside
yeah and just something that
really like especially you know it would
be cool to do something
with my boy oh that's a puppy you have
well yeah he's uh
a newfoundland a brown newfoundland he's
a really good dog he's the best
so he from what he's from another
country well he's from the from
the province of newfoundland which is
the east coast of canada
yeah i think i met someone there off the
internet once
halifax yeah halifax is yeah
they out there yeah they're uh it's nice
over there yeah
yeah it's it's uh cold off the ocean
yeah it seems really
like you just marry whoever you meet
first kind of thing
just make sure they're in your family
yeah yeah
well it's a different you know time's
out i think we'll see more of that
coming up in the future
we'll see a surge of numbers well i
think people are tired of just meeting
people outside of their families
honestly
i really do i think people are like oh
this isn't working out yeah a lot of
avenues of humanity aren't really
working out that well
it's kind of like a big shakeout just
happened
a riffraff yeah it's crazy yeah like
but man i'm glad to be a part of your
tribe tony and and i'm so thankful that
you came in
i'm grateful i got asked to be on and
and um
i i i feel i can call you a friend
yeah it was it was
i mean watches a lot of your stuff i
watched a lot of your stuff because not
because
uh not like i started watching some of
it just to make sure you were legit
right because i mean i just don't watch
much
of the like certain genre stuff right
and when i started watching i couldn't
stop watching
and i started losing track of time and
then when i started losing track of time
when i'm doing something i know i'm
doing something good
like i know i'm doing something that i'm
into so it's like it always kept me
interested
in what like you're and the diversity of
people that you'll have on or talk to
and then when you do the solo ones when
you just start reflecting about stuff
you say
funny like funny stuff obviously i find
hilarious because i can relate to so
much of it it's like my movie is dumb
and dumber right
it's like i can relate to it because
that's i'm freaking lloyd right but it's
like
it's like i catch myself i probably
bank 20 hours of whether youtube or pod
so i'm like no like this i can relate to
this guy this guy adds
like this show adds to my life even the
stupidity part of it as to my life
because i can relate
right but there's so many things that go
deep yeah
that you know like will stop me in my
tracks and it's hard to stop me in my
tracks
that's probably because i walk with
purpose that i got [ __ ] to do
and i got [ __ ] like got time to stop and
just waste time
because time is limited for me it's
interesting how as we get older it
starts to get a little bit limited if
somebody ever said you want to try to
stop tony manderson's tax i would have
said
no way please i'm gonna send nick in and
do this job
man no it's a pleasure man it's a it's a
pleasure to talk to somebody you know i
think i needed to be
around somebody today that's in the
program and just you know i don't think
you know just how much i needed that in
my own life today so i think even you
being here
is kind of like a service call in ways
that you probably can't even know
you know right right um and that is
reciprocal right that works both ways
yeah and it's cool man and yeah i'm here
for you and and we'd love to have you
back sometime and
and uh and just thank you bro thanks for
coming in today man it's an honor
i'm grateful i'm a great i'm honored to
to be on the show and and yeah it's cool
man you just never know how things are
happening i mean
literally what happened was i saw 15
seconds
of uh a video about you probably like
six weeks ago
and um probably the e60 special or
something that did it last year
maybe yeah and i'm not even sure what it
was it was like a no this was just a
clip it's just a clip on top and i was
like oh man this is so interesting
and nick is a huge grenade packers fan
and so i was like oh this is this seems
like it would be something that we could
talk about and then once
i looked more into it and saw the
recovery and stuff i was like oh this
should be pretty cool
no i appreciate it's uh and and i know
that
somebody that listens to this it'll help
somebody yeah
it'll help and for somebody to reiterate
that i am an ass
yeah where some people it'll it'll
be like if they can do it yeah why can't
i do it
why can't i get sober if they can get
sober yeah man right
yeah i think that we're made of the same
stuff
as far as the laws of nature oh it's a
simple recipe man
it's and we're just pretty con you know
why not me
yeah why not me man why not me get sober
and stay sober and not have to go back
yeah that's the way i look at it
yeah i think especially right now man
it's a good message for a lot of people
you know
um tony manners thank you so much bro
thanks brother
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i
can feel it in my bones
but it's gonna take a little
time for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my eye
shine that light on
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway
[Music]
now